she had a very sharp analytical mind she
thought very very uh precisely and
clearly about problems and she was also
um able to cultivate um the right people
in the right place she was a great
friend of Albert svens and she was a
great friend of Jonas socks and she was
a great friends of several of the
presidents of Yale University University
and she had um a great support system
John Paul who was her mentor and whose
chair the chair was named after him that
she held uh was his was was a great U
supporter of Dorothy so there were a lot
of different uh uh ways in which uh her
personality and her scientific ability
sort of uh came together in order to uh
Propel her forward in 1961 at a time
when there were only only six or seven
women in each entering class of medical
students and very few women on the
faculty uh Dorothy was promoted to full
professor of epidemiology and Pediatrics
and she at that time became the first
woman to hold the rank of full professor
at the school so I was thinking about uh
what it must have been like in the early
1940s when Dorothy started coming here I
was 7 years old at that time and I
didn't get to go to the beach because it
was a problem you might be able to catch
poliomyelitis by going to the beach for
a long time it was thought that the
virus gained access by going up through
the respiratory tract and the nose
directly into the brain and the fact
that it could uh access the nervous
system through the blood gave another
possibility in terms of the way the
virus could actually spread within an
individual she found that uh those uh
young monkeys that had been infected by
uh the oral root uh had virus in their
blood and that was the seminal uh
finding that uh she became so uh famous
and well recognized for the wh
commission Dorothy who was very much a
global Health Advocate and had been all
over the world studying the epidemiology
of polio virus so they commissioned her
to go to uh Russia and uh Snoop around
really find out how uh the vaccine was
working and she was able to get records
that evidently showed that there was a
tremendous U efficacy of the vaccine
that the cases of clinical
poliomyelitis uh had decreased and so on
the basis of a report that she wrote uh
the wh licensed the Sabin vaccine
without a large what we would call phase
three trial where you prove the efficacy
of the vaccine exactly 50 years after
Dorothy's promotion to full professor in
1961 we now have 71 women who are full
professors at the medical school and of
them 12 hold endowed shairs so I think
Dorothy would very much enjoy seeing the
success of the women who have followed
her